[Music]
we all have a favorite Disney Princess
and a favorite Hogwarts house where we
belong so why can't we mix these two
together and see in which house these
characters were sorted if you love
Disney Princesses and Harry Potter as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we are showing you ten Disney
Princesses reimagined in Harry Potter
Rapunzel
this princess loves to read books and
learn how to do all kinds of things but
she also cares a lot about others once
she gets the chance to escape her tower
in which house do you think she belongs
IRRI 1893 thinks that she belongs in
ravenclaw because she spent most of her
life doing many activities in her room
and let's not forget that young wizards
are sorted into a house at 11 years old
so that would totally represent her at
that time however things could change
now that she had the chance to meet new
people this is probably why Yuki Kyo
free imagines that Rapunzel was sorted
in Hufflepuff one thing is for sure
Flynn Rider belongs in Slytherin to
Jasmine this young princess knows what
she wants and how to get it he doesn't
mind breaking the rules and has a lot of
ambition this is probably why Willam
idea in 1991 thought that she belonged
in Slytherin her Patronus is obviously a
tiger not only because it is her pets
but also because the young woman is a
warrior however it looks like era 1893
couldn't figure out in which house
jasmine was sorted and they
intentionally did that because she
doesn't wear the same uniform as her two
princess friends no matter what he loved
that she brought a pet tiger to school
some people can speak to snakes so why
can't she learn how to speak to Tigers
Merida she was probably the most popular
Disney princess because a lot of artists
reimagined her in the Harry Potter world
everyone agrees that Merida was sorted
in Gryffindor because she is really
courageous we even think that she would
like to play Quidditch because she is
always ready for a new challenge
yukio agrees with that even though
Merida would suffer from some little
injuries but her friend Rapunzel would
always be there to take care of her
however it looks like friends can
sometimes fight when we look at how
1893 we imagined them at least we know
that Meredith does love her family when
we look at how Willem I J in 1991
reimagined her that's because her
petronas is a bear just like her mother
Ariel there are mermaids in Harry Potter
but they look nothing like the beautiful
Ariel but we all have to admit that the
Little Mermaid was really courageous to
leave everything she ever knew to live
on the land this is why era 1893
reimagined that she was sorted in
Gryffindor and this time she will be
really happy to see that she doesn't
have to change because Eric is in this
house - Ariel used to live under the sea
before she moved to the land and now she
wants to fly in the air however Willem I
J in 1991 saw her in a whole new
different way they thought that she
belongs in Hufflepuff because she is
nothing but kindness Anna the only thing
on a cares about is being with her
sister or falling in love as she loves
people so much that we think that she
would love to be sorted in hufflepuff
it looks like era 1893 agreed with us if
the characters were sorted in Hogwarts
houses since the beginning of the story
we would have seen that anna has nothing
to do with a Slytherin who thinks only
about himself she is much better with
Kristoff from hufflepuff but her sister
Elsa was sorted in ravenclaw instead as
we all know that she is really wise
however yukio reimagined something
totally different
as the two sisters decided to go to bow
batons instead the fringed Wizarding
school Snow White in which house do you
think that Snow White belongs even
though she was trying to escape her evil
stepmother who wanted to get rid of her
the first thing Snow White's thought
about was cleaning the little house that
she found we can see that she really
cares about others and this is why she
was sorted in Hufflepuff even though we
don't know a lot about her prince
we think that he is probably really
charming if he was sorted in Hufflepuff
- like a disney sir reimagined - the
same thing but this time there is a
little bit of Ravenclaw in her because
she is wearing Lunas glasses Belle there
is no doubt and we can all agree with
this Belle was sorted in ravenclaw when
era 1893 reimagined her she was arguing
with the Beast but we are sure that she
had the best arguments because she was
the
smartest however her prince was sorted
in Slytherin so we wouldn't be surprised
if he was the one who screamed louder
like a Disney sir reimagines Belle in a
better mood as she is simply reading a
book we bet that she would love to see
Hogwarts as library and then we have
Willem I J M 1991 who reimagined a young
princess who was courageous enough to
face one of her worst fears she turned
it into one of her greatest strengths
now that her petronas is a wolf Aurora
we don't know a lot about this princess
who slept all the time but with this
incredibly long nap
Aurora probably had the chance to think
a lot this is why era 1893 thinks that
she was sorted in Ravenclaw and she was
lucky enough to have a courageous prince
from Gryffindor who would be ready to do
anything to save her like a Disney sir
agreed with this because they thought
that Aurora should be sorted in
ravenclaw too but then we have Willem
idea in 1991 who thought that she would
look better in Slytherin and we have to
admit that we don't really understand
why but we love that her petronas is an
owl as it used to be one of her greatest
friends Pocahontas did you know that
Native Americans used to practice magic
too but when she moved to Europe
Pocahontas had to go to Hogwarts
and this courageous woman who wasn't
afraid of strangers was immediately
sorted in Gryffindor just like a Disney
serve reimagined her she even loves to
fly on a broom to get closer to her
friends the birds
she loves birds so much it is her
petronas as willem ijn 1991 reimagined
her it's an eagle because this animal
also represents that the princess is
strong and free we bet that she would
love to spend some time in the Forbidden
Forest and become friends with all these
creatures Tiana and last but not least
is the strong and fierce Tiana people
don't really know in which house she
belongs
she works hard she is smart the family
is also really important for her era
1893 thought that she was so nice that
she belongs in Hufflepuff this time we
can see her cooking something in
Hogwarts his kitchen and she is lucky
enough to have a prince by her side like
a Disney sir also thinks that she
belongs in Hufflepuff but this time he
a little more disappointed and we also
have Willem I J in 1991 who thinks that
she would be sorted in Ravenclaw because
she worked so hard in which house do you
think that you would be sorted don't be
shy to answer in the comment section
down below we love to hear what you
think and that's it for 10 Disney
Princesses reimagined in Harry Potter
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]